people love to gamble on twitch hell
there's a whole category on the platform
dedicated to slots and other casino
games and
recently these so-called crypto casinos
have exploded in popularity catching on
with big name
streamers like xqc and train wrecks but
the craziest part is this type of
gambling
might be extremely illegal
do you guys remember the order in which
i typically ask you to do things is it
like the video then subscribe to the
channel or the other way around
when does hitting the notification bell
come into play so you never miss
new content you know what it doesn't
matter just
do all of those things and have a great
day okay
strap in this is a complicated ass story
over the past
year or so a bunch of different crypto
casinos have gained a
ton of popularity on twitch a crypto
casino is
well exactly what it sounds like a
digital casino that offers a bunch of
different games and uses
cryptocurrency as its gambling currency
of choice
streamers and youtubers like train
wrecks xqc
miz kiff and ross stein have all been
either
sponsored by or use frequently
these sites like steak.com rubet and
gamdem on the surface this type of thing
looks fun as [ __ ] especially
when you're winning oh come on
but as soon as you look a little closer
as to what's going on here
red flags start to pop up left and right
especially considering that in the
united states the uk
and half a dozen other countries
stake.com
is illegal to use like if you jump into
the terms of service for stake.com it
says
plain as day that accessing the website
is prohibited in the countries i just
mentioned but
then how is it that the likes of xqc and
train wrecks are able to stream this
website to thousands of people well
by using a vpn of course now you might
be wondering isn't that a big
no-no i mean there has to be something
in twitch's terms of service about
accessing a prohibited gambling website
using
a vpn just don't worry we'll get there
first let me explain xqc's journey with
gambling then we'll explore how these
sites work
and what that means for twitch so
earlier this year
xqc jumped on the bandwagon of doing
gambling streams
sponsored by that stake.com company i
mentioned earlier
i did it again holy [ __ ] i did it again
i did it again full screen test [ __ ]
did it again
oh my god
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] dude
give me a hit like this take my mind i
need that
now during these streams xqc won a lot
and
lost just as much and before long he
started getting criticized for promoting
gambling to his relatively young
audience at first
xqc justified it saying that it was
harmless and he was just
doing what train wrecks and what
everyone else was doing for a while
things died down
until on may 28th when this thread from
esports personality
ollie ring started making the rounds on
social media
and in the thread ali highlights amongst
other things that this type of gambling
and specifically
accessing stake.com is highly illegal in
the state of texas
where xqc lives after xqc caught wind of
this
thread and other criticisms being thrown
in his direction
his response was well less than
enthusiastic
quote all drama related claims or
questions here's my official response
don't care keep maulding end quote
speaking of not taking criticism well
train wrecks has gotten pretty pissed
whenever he's been criticized for his
habit of gambling on stream why the [ __ ]
are you telling me to stop
you stop holy [ __ ] man do i need to
[ __ ] pull out my [ __ ] bank
accounts to show you guys i'm
financially set
oh my god shameless dude
but then roughly a week later xqc said
that he was done with gambling for good
and
that he could feel himself getting
addicted to the process
which i mean no [ __ ] i get addicted to
things very very easily
give it a quick look when you get the
chance but um thanks
i noticed my brain's kind of going crazy
as for train wrecks he has no intention
of stopping his gambling streams anytime
soon okay here's where things get
complicated
so most of these crypto casinos that
these streamers are using
are based in curacao which is a tiny
island in the caribbean
owned by the netherlands like i said
complicated
and since 1996 when they began granting
them in curacao it's been
incredibly easy to get a gambling
license a few different
ways but here's the catch these licenses
and the ways that you can get them
they're not exactly legit
see they're not illegal per se but the
bar is set
so low that you essentially just have to
fork over some cash
and voila you have a gambling license so
because cryptocurrency is so
unregulated these crypto casinos apply
for a gambling license in curacao
because
odds are they couldn't get one anywhere
else
now you can apply for something called
an ipe
gaming license through cursillo e-gaming
this is not
technically a gambling license but
rather an intellectual
property license but within the scope of
this
license you can apparently offer digital
games of chance
curse out e-gaming markets itself as a
one-stop shop for all things
crypto casino on top of giving you a
gambling license this company will also
do the following
set you up with an offshore company
complete with tax forms and a physical
business address
provide marketing services including
website development
and a logo they'll apparently provide
you with an eu-based
bank account and finally they offer
business consulting which
includes helping you develop your crypto
casino platform
now i might just be a dude who sits in
front of a camera and yells a lot but
even
i know this presents a potential giant
conflict of
interest like in my mind the company
that legally grants you the ability to
run a casino should
not also run your business development
and marketing department
another way to acquire curacao gambling
license is through the curacao internet
gaming association
or siga and siga is supposed to be
a government-sponsored agency the
implication
being that there's some actual
regulatory oversight happening
someone with the power to shut down
shady [ __ ] is
paying attention so to speak but if you
actually go to the siga website
it's well vague about pretty much
everything and eventually it just sends
you back to another curacao e-gaming
portal now the other license we're gonna
talk about which is mentioned on the
e-gaming and siga website
is something called the 1668
jazz master license and to the best of
my knowledge
this thing essentially lets you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
this is the license that both steak.com
and a bunch of other crypto casinos have
and if you do a quick google search for
1668
jazz master license you will quickly
find
that it's been accused of being a scam
now to be clear i'm not calling
stake.com a scam in fact it
seems to be one of the more reputable
crypto casinos out there
but what i am saying is that the
gambling casinos that are
scams work within this same licensing
infrastructure based out of places like
curacao and cyprus
one expat is a good example of this it's
a russian gambling site that partnered
with esl a while back it's been accused
of money laundering its founders fled
russia for fear of being arrested and
wouldn't you
know it it had that exact same 1668
jazz master license we covered that
situation and the partnership with esl
on this
show a few weeks ago what does all of
this mean for twitch
well on top of popular streamers
potentially breaking the law
by using websites that are prohibited in
the united states
they're using crypto casinos with
virtually no
regulatory oversight either from twitch
or an actual gambling commission in the
uk for example if something goes wrong
there's a bunch of different services
you can file a complaint with
and based on a law that passed in 2005
you can take that complaint to court
none of that seems to exist with these
curacao crypto casinos
on paper siga that agency i mentioned
earlier
is supposed to do this but every report
i've come across
says they will not step in for any sort
of dispute resolution
so short of dealing with the casinos
themselves
you're screwed in a quick google search
on any number of these
crypto casinos even the more legitimate
ones
brings a host of pissed off people
claiming that they've been scammed
the other big question surrounding
gambling on twitch is
are there any rules and the answer is
yes sort of
but not really allow me to explain
see a million different casino and
gambling blogs
state that gambling on twitch is
perfectly legal
as long as a few requirements are met
the person gambling is of legal age to
do so
gambling is legal in whatever country
state or city they live in
you should mark the gambling stream as
18 plus
and for mature audiences and the other
problem with these rules is that i
cannot for the life
of me find them anywhere in twitch's
terms of service
community guidelines or partnership
agreement in fact when doing a keyword
search
for gambling on both the tos and the
community guidelines page
that word never appears once the only
gambling related article
i could find anywhere on any official
twitch page
is an faq question about what to do if
you think
someone has a gambling addiction now
i've talked to multiple sources for this
story and they all tell me that yes
twitch has no official written down
rules
when it comes to gambling on stream one
person went so far as to say that you
don't even need to mark your channel as
18 plus
or for mature audiences if you don't
want to
that being more of a moral choice more
than anything else
so where the hell are these rules coming
from i honestly have
no idea streamers moist critical and
asthma gold have also
called out twitch for the gambling trend
on the platform
asthma gold said that they should just
ban gambling outright
while moist called the practice
dangerous i see gambling's become kind
of [ __ ] big these days
that's a little dangerous when you see
one of your favorite streamers get like
a huge payday
and you're like an impressionable 15 16
year old
when he said this about a month ago it
set off a bunch of drama between
him xqc and train wrecks because of
course it did and the most pressing
concern that i've heard from
everyone i've talked to is that one of
these days a big name streamer is going
to sign a sponsorship deal with
a less than reputable casino a casino
that
does rip off its user base and the whole
shiny house of cards is going to come
crumbling down which is when
and probably only when twitch will step
in with some song and dance about how
this is terrible and they're going to
make it safer for everyone involved
which
they'll probably publish in a long ass
blog post and then call it a day
and if that type of controversy ever
happens where twitch
does step in i'll be right here to tell
you about it
i don't gamble i i just i have an
addictive personality
it would not be good okay
it's a mugs game i don't know what that
means
you have a bad mug you know bad mug
don't gamble
no intention of stopping stopping
stopping the gambling